each season of American Horror Story has
been unique from the rest but there are
still some major common threads running
throughout the anthology installments
that definitely tie this hit thriller
series together between recurring
characters locations and clever
references scattered throughout there
are plenty of Easter eggs that connect
all six chapters of American Horror
Story together familiar faces the vast
majority of the show's characters have
appeared in just one season each but
there have been a handful who have
popped back in later seasons the first
character to bridge the divide was
pepper who made her debut in asylum as a
patient of Briarcliff Manor who was
committed for killing her own child and
freakshow we got to see what transpired
before those events we found out that
poor pepper was actually a member of the
cabinet of curiosities before she was
framed by her sister and brother-in-law
for the murder of their disfigured
infant Lucas sister Mary Eunice followed
suit which revealed that there was more
to her than the devilish possession we
saw in Asylum her return to freakshow
was much more pleasant and subdued dr.
Arden Marcy the realtor dr. Charles
Montgomery and Queenie are some of the
others who have come back for another
brief round of nefarious fun but actress
Sarah Paulsen is the MVP of comebacks
her celebrity psychic persona Billie
Dean Howard debuted in the first season
Murder House
and returned for season fives hotel and
her TV journalist alter-ego Lana winters
connected Asylum of the most recent
season Roanoke not just a name there
have also been several Winx 2 characters
to link the stories together
coven's Madison Montgomery for example
may have been related to the murder
houses original owners Charles and Nora
Montgomery if their shared last name
holds any significance and attorney
Harry Goodman from season 1 was probably
related to Asylum Sam Goodman especially
since they were both investigators it's
also probably no coincidence there were
two characters named Jack Colquitt who
were both detectives in different
generations in Roanoke Edward Mott was
the ancestor to freak shows dandy and
Gloria Maud plus those killer nurses
from Murder House came back into play in
Roanoke as well chances are the hunky
uper driver red snow might have also had
some kind of connection to coven
character Myrtle snow unless his name
was actually a nod to Game of Thrones
undead hero but that'd just be crazy
right theoretical throwbacks even where
names and actual role reprisals failed
to appear there's still some characters
that draw us back to something familiar
from the past for example
Roanoke's woods which is rumored to be
the original supreme from coven unless
forget that cricket said he was trained
in New Orleans which is where the actors
other American Horror Story persona
spend some time during comin Plus Billy
Dean made a direct mention of the
Roanoke colony all the way back in
Murder House meanwhile it's widely
believed that Oliver thredson from
asylum was actually the faceless
therapist that treated dandy Mott in
freakshow and it's probably no
coincidence that the new season included
all the pig masks after season ones
Derrick harped on his Pigman fear so
hard running rules
another common thread found throughout
all six seasons lies in the supernatural
rules in play ghosts for example
continually exist as haunting visible
presences that appeared to be confined
to the locations of their death
Bucky net physical and sometimes deadly
interactions with the living around them
spirit mediums are also regularly
brought into play and witchcraft is
obviously a very real practice
throughout the series demonic
possessions run rampant throughout the
show and multiple installments feature
vampires thirst for blood altogether
these shared mythologies make up the
sinister backbone of the whole body of
the show and every season relies on them
somatic threads that's not all that
bleeds together about American Horror
Story seasons there's also the common
themes behind the various characters
motives and actions mobbing issues seem
to loom large for a lot of the men on
the show there have been several woman
who killed off their husbands along the
way as well bigamy is another big one
just how many girlfriends did Evan
Peters characters have anyway and let's
not forget how pop culture obsessed so
many of Sarah Paulsen's characters have
been speaking of which visual cues it's
no mistake that some seasons of American
Horror Story have given fans a sense of
deja vu
several the camera angles throughout
have been set up as direct references to
stories passed like the repeat opening
scenes from Murder House and Roanoke and
all that time the cameras spent looking
at staircases eagle-eyed fans might have
also spotted the Roanoke butcher's
cleaver and some other throwback weapons
among those that were laid out in hotel
and even the element of literally
two-faced characters like Bette and dot
from freak show and Edward mordrake
seemed to a foreshadow what would later
come for the cast members portraying
them after all Sarah Paulsen's
appearances in multiple roles in the
subsequent Seasons Hotel in Roanoke
could be a tribute to her ability to
double up and West Bentleys Hotel
characters certainly had two minds
pushing and pulling his behaviors right
sinful significance one of the biggest
takeaways that seems to come through
with American Horror Story is its
grander statement
cept of sin a lot of fans think the
individual seasons represent the layers
of hell in Dante's Inferno while others
think they're each playing on the seven
deadly sins both sides seem to have some
basis in the show's reality murder house
for example involved a lot of bedroom
behavior by its characters so it might
fall under the lust category an asylum
was filled with fraud and false witness
coven ad heresy written all over it
freakshow dealt a lot with the concept
of pride hotel meanwhile was all about
wrath and gluttony and Roanoke had more
than one instance of adultery and
coveting not to mention tons of violence
the fact that hotel included an actual
Ten Commandments killer even seemed like
a giant nada these long-held theories
whether or not the future seasons
continued to correspond to these wicked
markers remains to be seen but one
thing's for sure there's a bigger
picture here that's only beginning to
reveal itself thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]